people's ears noses feeling that
windchill all the work so this is our
field training expedition so we're just
going out overnight tonight's and once
we get out there we're gonna test the Y
equipment so set up the tent and see how
everything works so we put a really good
idea for once we actually get out in the
field I guess part of going out there is
the camera crews we got to go through
the same training as everybody else so
myself and drew are trying to pay
attention and trying to avoid the urge
to take too many pictures because they
leave plenty of time for that I guess so
we're gonna go sleep outside tonight
first time in Antarctica sleep outside
damn we've just have a quick meeting in
our little Bay there with the white
board and go through a few checks make
sure that we've ticked every box and we
haven't forgotten anything vital and
they're more like a mess wander around
to the sign out book around the front
sign out for the night in the back one
in the front its roll
[Music]
all right so this is gonna be our home
for the night so this is our area here I
can't kind of it a nice neat line going
that make sense
[Music]
which tender you boys end I can never
put butch it's pretty cozy
yeah a couple of wee things tonight that
little posh in the top there's really
good spot to dry things out sighs my
socks will go straight up there you
strip down and put on a new layer I
generally don't take my socks off I do
wear a hat yeah warm also come on often
if it's a really cold night Lynette
Gator on and right up and around you can
use you answers yeah yeah
good night design and pull that over
your eyes because you will find these
quite light when the sun's blaring being
on you is this the start cause it's
gonna get this done this is gonna get 24
hours of sunlight
[Music]